[man yells]
Not gonna happen.
Not in the foggiest is
that ever gonna happen.
I'm Dwayne Fields, a polar explorer.
I've spent so many years
traveling in and doing work
and carrying out expeditions
in the arctic regions.
I'm the first Black man of Britain
to have walked to the magnetic north pole.
Today, we're going to be focusing on
polar-exploration movies,
and we're going to be judging
how realistic they are.
[Doc panting]
Jerry: Take deep breaths, Doc.
He's saying, "Take a deep breath."
What you want to do is
slow your breathing down,
control your breathing.
It stops you from panicking.
What you do is you get your arms out,
you kick your legs,
and you wiggle your body up onto the ice.
Unless he's got an injury
where he can't kick.
Jerry: All right, take the rope.
Go to Doc.
He seems relatively calm
despite the shock that
he would be feeling.
I've done exercises
where I've thrown myself
into a hole in ice
just to get you accustomed
to the feeling and the shock.
You get in there, you dip yourself down.
[breathes slowly]
Now you can talk to me,
because now I've brought
everything down a slower pace.
Jerry: She's coming to you.
You're putting another body,
whether it's a dog's body, human body,
another body in danger.
If the dog falls through the
ice, it's going to panic.
It might cause the ice to crack more.
He's also 8, maybe 9 meters away.
He could easily throw
the rope that distance
and save risking the dog's life.
Some of the best-trained dogs in the world
still only follow one command.
Go left, go right, go straight, go down,
come back, sit, jump.
In terms of, "Put this over
Doc's head and shoulder,"
that's not realistic. Let's be honest.
[Jerry yelling]
[dogs barking]
If I'd walked across some ice
and someone behind me
fell through the ice,
I'd assume that there's a weakness there.
My first thing is lay down,
spread myself as flat as I can,
get a board, get a piece of branch,
anything to spread my weight
and to assist the rescue.
Throw the rope to the person.
I wouldn't go towards them.
I'd give it a 6, because,
like most people,
who doesn't want a well-trained dog?
[ice cracking]
What they're hoping for
is that sample of ice
has trapped bubbles of air,
which gives them an idea
of what the atmosphere
was like at the time.
[ice cracking]
You don't know what the
extent of it's going to be.
It does crack.
It's a [imitates ice cracking] sound.
[ice cracking]
If a crack starts to form,
you get away from the crack.
You raise the alarm, and
What I found was we'd
go to sleep in the tent
on a bit of frozen ocean,
and we'd wake up to small sounds.
And only when it's silent,
there isn't much wind,
can you hear the slight cracking,
and it almost sounds echo-y
as it echoes and resonates
through the ice itself.
Grabs the samples that he's collected.
It looks like four or five of them.
Now, these things aren't light.
You cannot jump a 12-foot,
10-foot gap
carrying 20, 25 kilos. You can't do it.
[ice cracking]
Jack!
Not gonna happen.
Not in the foggiest.
Can't imagine he would have
been sat in the office,
the office tent, and thought,
"Oh, I'll just keep my ice ax on me."
I've kept it in my bag,
to the side or the back of my bag.
Generally, I don't keep it around my waist
unless I'm using it at that point.
If I'm climbing an ice
wall for recreational usage
or when I go for a walk in high altitude
or snowy terrain, I'll carry one.
In case you slip, you can
use it to stop yourself.
I generally don't walk
around with an ice ax on me.
But the ice itself is what's holding you.
As long as it's cold enough,
the ice is hard enough,
it will hold your weight.
They were made of wood
with maybe a steel tip.
Nowadays they're made of aluminium mostly,
so they're super
lightweight, super strong.
You could comfortably support yourself.
And I'd give it a four.
Entertainment value, it's
an entertainment film.
[woman yells]
She's holding something which
is metal with exposed skin.
You don't want to do that in the cold.
What happens is your skin
is always going to be
slightly warmer than the
thing that you're touching.
That thin layer of moisture on your skin
or warmth on your skin will melt the ice
on the metal object just slightly
so you almost get stuck to it.
Normally, what you'd do is
you'd allow it to warm up.
You'd warm it up slowly using,
arguably, people say, no, use hot water;
other people say use warm water.
Oh, my God.
That looks like advanced frostbite.
If it wasn't frostbite
and it was frostnip,
you might see some discoloration.
You might feel some numbness,
some stinging maybe.
I had my goggles on, which was perfect.
I had a bit of material
just covering the goggle,
and it was just rubbing on my nose,
and where that material got so cold,
the end of my nose turned
darker and peeled off.
The outer layers of skin were dead.
With frostbite, the cold
causes all the cells to burst.
If the cell wall is burst, that
cell is dead. It's useless.
The skin cells, they're
all the way through
to the nerve endings.
Nothing?
I'm going to have to amputate this.
No, no way.
Get them taken off as quickly as possible.
Prevent further damage.
It really does get like that.
They start to change color.
It goes from maybe a pale
color to a dark blue.
Then it starts to get darker and darker
until it turns black.
Now, the way you can avoid it is
we layer up, as many layers as you can.
Give that scene a solid 8, 9 out of 10.
[polar bear growling]
Oh, I like that.
He's taken shelter in
this natural formation,
a cave of some sort.
And it looks like he's piled up the snow
at the entrance to keep
the air inside warm,
which is a good idea, but
you should be careful,
'cause you don't want the
carbon dioxide to build up.
[polar bear growls]
Polar bears are brilliant hunters.
They've got one of the best
senses of smell in the natural kingdom.
And you can hear it outside
taking big breaths in.
And that's a telltale sign.
It's walking around, sniffing the air,
tracking down where that
smell is coming from.
[man yells]
[polar bear growls]
Remember, these things
are used to hunting seal
and finding carcasses washed
up on beaches from miles away.
Normally, they'd find a
seal underneath the ice.
They'll dig it out, take
the young, take the seal,
and that's their meal.
So it's doing exactly what
it would normally do there.
[polar bear growls]
[man yells]
Exactly what you're supposed to do.
Loads of noise,
be ready to defend
yourself if you have to,
and use the flare.
People do get attacked by
polar bears. It happens.
They tend to happen near a settlement,
or it tends to happen when the polar bear
is either ill, finds it difficult to hunt.
I'll give this one a solid 9 out of 10.
No, thank you.
I like these better.
You can see some frost
starting to form on his jacket.
And I think I can see a little bit forming
on his mustache as well,
so that's pretty accurate.
You don't want to stop for a main meal
every two or three hours.
So what you do is you
have a bag with food,
the calorific content is very high,
and you put your hand in your pocket,
chop that in your mouth every so often.
Now, inevitably you're
going to get someone
who eats a lot more than you.
And part of a team dynamic is you stop
and you share out whatever you've got.
Now, if everyone does that,
it balances out over the
day or over the week.
Look at me.
Pizza.
Cheeseburgers.
See, sometimes when I'm out,
I look forward to having a Jelly Baby
at the next allocated stop
that me or my team have decided.
Could be any treat.
Just having something to look forward to,
it helps you take that next step.
So, I think that's spot on.
When I first went to the Arctic,
I think two, three days before the end,
we'd been walking for about,
22 days was the total journey time.
We'd been walking for about 19 hours,
and I remember thinking,
"Oh, gosh, I'm hungry."
And as soon as I said that,
my mind started to think
about a chicken biryani
and a lamb korma that I'd
had three weeks earlier.
So I kept looking at my teammates, saying,
"Oh, gosh, it's like I
can almost smell it."
You keep going in that direction.
Polar winds, it feels agonizing.
When you see these images
of people in polar extremes
and around their eyes are blistering up
and their lips are cracked,
it's the wind for the most
part that's doing that.
Having one huge jacket is good,
but the best option is
have multiple layers
to trap multiple layers of air.
[wind whooshing]
There he doesn't have any goggles on.
Luckily, the little girl, I think it is,
does have goggles on.
And it must be so scary to think that
you can't open your
eyes to try and navigate
using whatever tools are available.
[wind whooshing]
What looks like snow or mist
— or, it looks like mist,
it's actually snow. It's called spindrift,
and that's the wind kicking
up a small amount of snow
and making it swirl and blow past.
Generally, at about 10, 15 kilometers,
it will start picking up bits of snow.
So you can almost tell
roughly what the wind speed is
by how much snow is being been moved along
and how high up that is.
The details such as the frost,
I'd say I'd give it a solid 8,
maybe 8 1/2 out of 10.
Man: Observe my signals.
One pull on the tube
means half a fathom slack.
Ready!
It just instantly brought me back to
the books I've read about
Shackleton and Scott
and ships being stuck in
Antarctica over winter
because they'd become trapped in the ice.
And then burning bits of
the ship just to keep warm.
There should be a surgeon here.
They're just below, Mr. Collins.
Cold water, your body loses temperature
about 20 to 25 times quicker.
He's using what looks like a spear
to chisel away at the ice.
At this time in history, there weren't any
tried-and-tested methods
for stuff like this.
It was, you did what you had to do
using the tools that you had to hand.
I've read accounts of people
chopping away at the ice using a pickax,
tying ropes to ships and
pulling them backwards
and then pulling them forwards again,
and taking a different route
and using the dogs to pull
and going ahead and breaking up the ice
ahead of the ship.
With modern ships, they've
got hardened hulls.
So the hulls may be twice as thick.
It's made of steel.
It's ready for impacting ice.
They've got powerful engines
that can break the ice up.
They've got radar to detect
the thickness of the ice.
I think the Arctic has
this mysticism about it,
where — we like familiarity.
The thing with Arctic is,
it changes every single year.
The maps that we have this year,
they won't be perfect,
because come next year,
the ice has fallen, some has melted.
Because so much of it isn't visible,
there's a lot that we don't know,
and that doesn't sit well
within the human mind, does it?
Our imaginations start
playing games with us.
I love this. I'd give
this a solid 9 out of 10.
MacReady: We're not
getting out of here alive.
But neither is that thing.
Why would you say that?
You're perfectly capable,
at least three of you,
perfectly capable.
You've got all the tools to escape.
You've got all the means to make fire
and to get a good distance away.
If something's happened and
you're isolated, you leave.
You head to the nearest populated area
or a place you could get help
and you radio back what's happened
or what you need or what
support's necessary.
I notice that they are lighting
what looks like TNT?
Is it trinitrotoluene rods?
They're lighting it right
next to their chest,
but they've also got other
rods right next to their chest.
I don't think that's something you'd do.
[bomb explodes]
Yes, fire is a good option.
Every single predator
I've ever come across
is afraid of fire. Simple fact.
The only things that
are attracted by fire,
generally, are insects.
I don't think it's ever a good idea
to blow up a hole in
the middle of your camp.
You've got what looks like
a tracked vehicle there,
which is, it could be some kind of
small bulldozer or lifter.
You've got the means to escape
and to survive short term.
The biggest threat out there
is never going to be the wildlife.
If you prepare for that, it's fine.
If you carry a shotgun
for the most extremes of circumstances.
The biggest threat's always
going to be exposure.
Making sure I'm prepared for whatever
the weather is going to throw at me.
No, not likely to face an alien. [laughs]
I love a sci-fi movie more than most,
so I'm going to give this one a 5,
but in terms of how realistic it is,
I'm sorry, it's not doing much.
Han: Don't do this, Luke.
Come on, give me a sign here.
I know there's going to be a
bright "Star Wars" superfan
that's going to come and tell me
exactly what animal that is.
Han: But it'll keep you warm
till I get the shelter up.
You should've had that
up at the first hint
that the weather was going
to turn, had the shelter up.
Secondly, in a survival situation,
you take shelter where you can get it.
I've heard of people
sheltering in animal carcasses
in desert environments
where they've come across a dead animal,
but I've never heard of anyone
finding an animal big enough
in an arctic environment to sleep inside.
The average polar bear's probably about 8,
8 1/2 feet tall, and
that's it standing up.
To fit inside of a polar bear torso,
it's going to be a lot of work.
[wind whooshing]
If you're in the Arctic and
you need shelter quickly,
your best bet is to
try and dig a snow hole
or just pile up some snow
to give you a break from the wind.
Gosh, I'm a "Star Wars" fan.
I'd give this a 5 out of 10.
[men grunting]
Man: Hold the back!
Hold it at the back!
In Antarctica, the terrain is treacherous.
Antarctica has the longest
mountain range in the world.
It's got areas where it's ice rubble.
You can see in this scene,
there were piles of ice,
they were pushing this little long boat.
That vision of seeing
completely flat arctic tundra
or completely flat terrain, it's a myth.
It very, very rarely presents itself.
Man: I'm not doing this, it's stupid.
Look at the hull.
You're supposed to be
captain of this cutter,
and you're tearing it apart!
Nowadays, I think people
tell you more about
what you're doing and why you're doing it.
I've been on expeditions
where similar things have happened.
We were walking across the Arctic,
we're day 10, day 11 in.
My pulk, which is my sled,
just started to feel heavier.
And I realized that it was irrational
when I went to my teammate,
they'd walked ahead,
I said, "Look, my pulk's heavy.
You guys packed it wrong."
My teammate laughed at me and said,
"But, Dwayne, you packed
your pulk yourself."
Fundamentally, I hadn't
eaten properly that morning
and the evening before.
And that's all it took
for me to feel weaker,
tired, drained, and fatigued.
I'd give it a 6 or 7.
I'd give it a 7 out of 10.
So, my journey into exploration
was a bit of a strange one.
I googled North Pole.
A few names popped up,
and one of the names was Matthew Henson.
And I was drawn to Matthew Henson
because he was a Black man.
And I thought, "I've
never seen a Black man
in any arctic book or anything."
I think when people watch TVs and movies
and shows and read, the
biggest myth they get
is that only one type
of person goes there.
You always see, it's a white male
who's about 50 years old,
bearded, who's well weathered,
got some money behind them that does this,
and that's not the truth.
We want more women doing it.
We want more people from all
different backgrounds doing it.
If we follow what we're seeing on TV
and in magazines and historical accounts,
you'd think that no women
had ever been to the pole.
Thanks for watching.
If you liked this, click
on the video above.